so I'm a big calendar person I really
like having a deadline when I was
started writing this book my due dates
in like 4 weeks or something like that
and it's not like I look at it
frequently but it's just out there it's
this thing that gets put in your psyche
and somehow you can work backwards so
much easier from a date so it sounds so
silly but most humans will say well in
one year or 3 years or 5 years I'm like
put it on your calendar like whatever
that actual timeline is and then try to
work backwards and then for most goals I
believe in short-term goals so like I
might have a really big vision for for
10 years or 20 years but as I get closer
I might realize oh God actually nope
that's not what I want so allowing
yourself that freedom to not want to be
the hot sexy Rich millionaire with
Bentley's and instead say oh no what I
actually want to do is I want to talk
about what I want to talk about with
whom I want to talk about owning
companies I want to and having no master
that's what Rich looks like for me and
if you had stuck with your original
goals that wouldn't have been the case
hey it's EV Carmichael and I watch these
videos every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hash believe in the comments below so I
can celebrate with
you so today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Cody
Sanchez Joy what's your purpose what's
the thing that's driving you to do all
the stuff yeah a couple things one time
you know I think it's really useful if
you're wondering what your purpose is if
you're struggling with am I doing the
right thing day in and day out I like to
think about a tombstone and mine and I
remember one time I had a crazy dream
and in the dream I basically walked in
the cemetery as one does and my
Tombstone came up in front of me and at
the time I was in private equity and it
just said like managing director Cody
Sanchez and I was like oh GR
what that's going to be the Legacy I'm
like a managing director in a private
Equity Firm kill me and so I think sort
of looking at your Tombstone and it
doesn't have to be work-related it could
be you know father that might be an
incredible thing to have in your
Tombstone right and so uh that made me
change my perspective and now I hope the
legacy is that we bring more humans into
ownership that's the second ideal I'm
play idea I'm playing around with which
is I think more humans skin in the game
uh in some way shape or form it's the
only way to feel like you have you have
ownership in this world you have
something that you are striving for in
building and most people rent their
Apartments these days or their houses
most people work at jobs where they
don't have equity in it only 15% of
humans actually own stocks which would
be equity in companies by and large
we're becoming a nation or a world of
renters when we started you know over
the last century finally becoming owners
after years of surfd and so um that is
my mission is I want more human beings
to have their little their little plot
of land figuratively or physically uh
because I think that that changes the
way we look at the world then we start
to become stewards of it then we start
become stewards of our country you don't
burn down the building that you own
right you fix it you renovate it you
build on it so that's what I hope our
mission is I hope that when I'm dead I
hope there's a bunch of people that
would never have owned anything and now
own something and they get to pass that
on to the next Generation cuz otherwise
just the guys at the top own everything
I mean one out of four houses last year
got bought by three companies in the US
single family houses we don't even own
our homes anymore and so that I think
needs to change there's a superpower uh
it's called yes and instead of saying
the word no like no I don't have time no
I don't know how to do that no I'm not
interested in that I learned the
superpower from one of my mentors who
actually worked at Barclays um by saying
yes and I'll need to study X before we
execute on that yes and the deliverable
date for that will be a little bit
longer the more nose you do early in
your career the worse your career goes
in my opinion I don't think you should
like ever almost ever tell your boss no
you should really be looking for lots of
yeses in your life and then give a
caveat on how to get there yes I can
take on that project and I'm going to go
look for an intern because it's
definitely going to take more than the
60 hours I work already boss cool now
the framework that I use for this as
I've gotten less time and maybe slightly
more successful is four things learn
earn expand connect so before I say yes
now I say one is it going to teach me
something new a skill that I need to
utilize two is it going to help me earn
more even if I don't earn more in that
minute although if I do I like that I
like making coin uh three is expand is
it going to expand the geography uh that
I'm able to tackle is it going to expand
the you know sectors that I'm able to
work in and fourth is connect will this
get me in a room or in contact with
people that are going to better me so I
might say to my boss he wants me to do a
new project but I realize that it's in
Latin America so that would be an area
I'd like to go to or I realize it's
going to connect me with a bunch of
influencers of which I had no experience
with before learn to say more yes and
and learn to get rid of the word no
early on all of us have willpower issues
and all of us can benefit from a little
eyee over the shoulder and the reason
why I think we can really benefit is
because I remember when I was at Goldman
Sachs and they were watching us like
crazy I was never on social media I was
never off because I wanted to
get out of that office I knew I was
going to have to do long hours and I
wanted to get out of there when I was
done I never understood the Silicon
Valley foosball make them stay here all
the time thing I'm like come here give
it intense maybe do a workout break or a
walk in between come back to intense and
then go live your life
you know and if you're like me you're
going to work way more than that but
like be here when you're going to be
here like think about work like
meditation you should be so singularly
focused that all distraction sort of
Fades away and if you do that then you
actually have to you have to work less
because you're so much more effective
but I remember early on in my career you
know it's why I couldn't stay at
Vanguard actually because I was sitting
at a desk and I was trying I was like
you know those Ducks where underneath
the surface they're paddling like crazy
but on top they're smooth that was me I
was drowning I didn't know anything
about Finance I'd come from journalism I
everybody was smarter than me everybody
went to Harvard and Sanford Etc I went
to Arizona State Harvard to the West as
you said um and uh and I remember one of
the my teammates came up and was trying
to talk to me about lunch planning and
stuff and I was like CeCe I I'm focused
I don't have time to talk about any of
this I'm I'm here man we could talk like
after work but like I'm here right now
and that happened like a few times and I
wasn't be trying to be a jerk I just
couldn't be distracted because then I
lost my focus entirely and I probably
have a little ADHD and so it would
derail me for like 30 40 minutes and I
remember that happened and then my boss
at one point was like your team thinks
that you would leave dead bodies behind
you and I was like huh really why
they're like well you don't pay
attention when they come up to your desk
you don't do party planning I was like
guy I am here to do a job and I going to
I would never
like run over somebody to do the job but
I will be singularly focused to get it
done also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight our favorite lessons from the
video that will inspire you to remember
what you learned today and actually
apply them the worksheet will also give
you space to write down what your key
takeaways are and your specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want to work designed
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
listening listening's greater than
speaking so I have a rule called the 10x
Rule and no this isn't about doing 10x
the work this is about you focusing on
giving 10x more than you receive the
biggest thing that you can give to
somebody is actually listening in a
conversation the smartest wealthiest
people I know they don't talk a lot in
fact my friend actually had dinner with
Warren Buffett no big deal humble brag
and Warren Buffett did one thing he said
when I asked Alex afterwards what did
Warren say to you he said it wasn't what
Warren said to me it was the questions
that he asked he's like I talked 99% of
the meeting with the sage of Omaha and
the reason is is because the guy is
always letting other people talk because
who is smarter the one that gives
everybody the answers or the one that
takes all the answers by listening you
make people feel better because
everybody likes to talk about them M
themselves and simultaneously you're
getting all the answers so he sat there
with Warren Buffett getting no
information and giving all of it that's
why you should always listen instead of
speak this guy Scott came up with this
idea it's pretty brilliant it's that you
should spend as much time as you can
acquiring a diverse set of skills and
stacking them up vertically think about
it like this Steve Jobs became obsessed
with calligraphy AKA letters and types
and fonts and skin and Aven design which
is why all the Mac products are gorgeous
and then you look at like PC or Dell
like what like so not pretty he became
then obsessed with coding and software
those things have nothing to do with
each other but because the skill
stacking of all of them created
something really rare what did he get a
billion dollar a multi-billion dollar
monstrosity of a company you can become
a top 1% in the world through doing
10,000 hours of backstrokes like Michael
Phelps or you can become a top 1% in the
world by stacking a top 20% in multiple
things my skill stack for instance is
that like I'm a top I don't know 10 to
20% investor top let's call it 10 to 20%
marketer top 10 to 20% public speaker
you know 20% is social media and maybe a
top 20% writer that all gets us to being
top 1% in exactly what I do and you can
do the same thing but I paid to learn
all of those skills if you are in a room
where everybody in there has already
accomplished the stuff that you want to
accomplish The Impossible nature of it
just floats away it becomes much more
reasonable that you are going to achieve
something big if you around a bunch of
other people that are doing it and the
same thing's true like look yourself in
the face right now and ask yourself are
you really around the friends that you
need to be to get to the place you want
to get to are you having the
conversations that that necessitates are
you pushing yourself are you getting
pushed by other peoples do you have an
accountability good group for the good
things not the bad things do your
friends say to you hey where were you on
Friday night not hey what did you build
this weekend
the difference between those two
conversations is the difference between
the bank account you want and the one
that you got if you want to get rich
Master negotiation there
is really one universal truth to getting
money and that is that you have to ask
for it in a myriad of ways you got to
start asking for it in your salary and
negotiate early on you got to start
asking for it by trying to get stuff
outed discount instead ofay paying full
price you got to start asking for it by
doing deals and investing in things and
figuring out how to structure those how
to get what you want how to negotiate
for more time how to negotiate for more
responsibility the undertone of money is
negotiation if you can figure out how to
get people to give you what you want
more often than you give away what
someone else wants you'll have a bigger
bank account there's 10 steps to buying
a business first step to buying a
business is understanding that the
opportunity is out there um and that
it's possible to do with not a lot of
cash if you want to and that that
business could potentially replace your
9 to-5 totally doable second is deal
Clarity which means hey I know exactly
what type of business would be good for
me I asked myself we have 25 questions
we ask you but I've asked myself these
25 questions third is origination how do
I find a business uh where are they
located fourth is due diligence this
would be this section so how do I know
if this is a good business that really
does what it says it does where the
owner actually only works 20 hours a
week and it makes this much amount of
money that they say it does so I know
what I'm getting myself into fourth is
negotiating how do I negotiate well with
the seller in order to get what I want
six is selling you so how do I convince
the seller that I am the person to take
over their little baby that they've
built their whole lives or that they
spent their whole lives building seven
is going to be um financing so how do I
get the money to actually do this deal
eight is closing so how how do I take
this uh how do I take this business with
my attorney and my accountant and
actually close the deal overall uh nine
is the first 90 days and then 10 is
growth and so if you think about buying
a business that way you have you I don't
think you can just listen to a podcast
like this go out and buy a business I
don't think that's a good idea for
anybody listening today I think in fact
you have 30 to 60 90 days of learning
like you if you spent 20 to 30 minutes
in let's say something like our course
or reading a book or whatever you want
to do um you could learn in 30 to 6090
days what your dealbox is how to do
under ready what a good deal looks like
for you Etc and by the end of 30 to 90
or 30 to 90 days you could move forward
on executing a a small business
transaction now do I think that you
would be a pro at it no but I think you
would have enough understanding to where
you're not going to bankrupt yourself uh
if you follow the steps it's it's not
easy but it's simple the woman you are
now Y what would you say to that person
who's a little
scared thinking I shouldn't do this
because I'm safe and I really safe it
was an illusion always start sooner than
you think do it before you're ready um
you'll never feel ready sort of like you
know that conversation people have with
kids like you're never ready I feel like
people should say that same thing to
people who want to become an
entrepreneur the difference maybe is
yeah like the people who want to have
kids like you never you're never ready
just have the kid you're like you're
never ready just do the thing yeah um
great point but I actually think I'm a
little different like we were talking
about mutual friends we have we I have a
couple mutual friends that are like I
slept on a couch I lived on the floor
and I do not think you have to do that
no absolutely not I think that you could
be a little scared and you could tiptoe
your way into it and and so if I was
talking to my 19-year-old self I'd say
start tiptoeing sooner you don't have to
a big jump tiptoe I think our mind is
the hardest thing to conquer um because
it's there's so many tentacles to it you
know I think about it a little bit like
like a Hydra it's got all of these heads
that you have to figure out money is
actually I think one of the easier
things to break through but your mind is
is difficult and so I think um at
contrarian thinking we try to get you to
the Pinnacle which is you know can you
be a self-actualized human who can
really think for yourself um and we just
we just launched an Instagram account
actually focused on this with the idea
that I loved the stoic movement you know
I think what Ryan holiday has done is
really really cool I'm a big fan um and
I thought we needed one additional level
which is stoicism is like whatever
happens in life you know I will handle
with sort of this calm ability to think
uh rationally about it and I kind of
think we need one level on top of that
which is I'm not just going to stand by
calmly to all that's around not that
that's what I'm saying uh stoicism is
but I'm going to really think critically
about the world around me and I think
today we are there's an assault on on
our Intelligence on our attention and so
contrarian thinking is this it's a push
back I want to get to the Great who
questioned all things and stood out from
the herd and I think that's what you
guys do here you're willing to be that
Devil's Advocate you talked about and I
hope that's what we can do we can start
shining a light on humans that said
things that at the time people thought
they shouldn't have we need more of that
in this world one of the biggest deals
I've seen go sideways was largely
because of one thing that was the assets
of they had the expensive stuff that
started to fail or break in this
instance it was trucks so it's really
normal pre-sale for people to Band-Aid
equipments that means that the repairs
don't come out of their p&l before they
sell or their show on their balance
sheet it looks to you like they've got a
fleet of great trucks use but behind the
scenes there are a bunch of lemons you
need to get a third party to Value their
assets it's really easy you can Google
search third party valuation experts uh
but make sure you do it let's say you're
like me and you don't want to take all
that risk on you want to diversify your
risk you want to like spread it out
across a bunch of people there's a lot
of ways that you can do that you can get
seller financing you can raise from
investors you can use multiple loans and
you can actually learn how to do this
here for free you can use this small
business calculator you can do deals
that help other people grow just by you
sourcing the deals to them typically for
me I want 12 months of emergency fund
cash to make sure if anything goes
sideways I'm a okay one of the best
things that happens to people young I
believe is
getting put in jobs and positions where
you are told no continuously building up
an armor of no of you're not good enough
of you know this doesn't work really
makes a lot things easier in life and so
for me I was in finance and I was doing
sales so I was during the 2008 financial
crisis doing investment sales to people
who were losing everything at that
moment you could imagine me calling and
saying you know hey I want you to put
through this order and I want you to to
come into this IPO and people like what
is wrong with you like lose my phone
number for eternity the world is ending
and uh and I did that for years and
years and years and so once you have
failure so repeatedly you realize that
you're not going to die right people
telling you no people telling you that
you're not good enough it hurts at first
and then at some point it stops hurting
you know you look at little young boys
right and the way they speak to each
other like you know you're so ugly that
girl's never going to say yes when you
ask her out women we don't have that as
much we're like honey you're beautiful
you're perfect you're great right and so
we don't build up this armor of nose and
I think as a woman like if I was single
you know what I'd go do I'd go to a bar
and I would try to talk to as many men
as I could and I would try to get turned
out as many times as I could in person
because then guess what Tinder swiping
who cares you know a date doesn't go
Riot who cares because you've built up
an armor that shows that that has
nothing to do with you as a human and
everything to do with you just have to
take a few more swings you sort of
talked about having this list of
operators for those of us that are just
trying to get one operator for whatever
business how does one go out and
actually Source an operator yeah it's I
think it's your immediate Network so I
call it the COI effect which is
basically you're looking for centers of
influence but you are the center of
influence so if you think about it right
now for instance I have Laura Laura is
my property manager and she runs the
crew that cleans my house in Austin for
instance she's awesome so we went out of
town for 4 weeks and we had to have all
these projects done on the house so I
was like I need the the the fences
stained I need the patio redone I need
you to buy a couple of these plants I
need you to do this I need you to take
my car into X Y and Z and I just kind of
said do all that charge me what you will
and it was a micro project and at the
end of the four weeks she had done all
of it she had done everything that I
wanted her to do and she saved me a
grand by not taking it to one dealership
and taking it to another one and so when
she did that um I basically got with her
afterwards and was like well you take
50% of what you saved me because uh you
when you save me money you're going to
make money love that and then I
basically said you're really competent
of this so what if we made you our
office manager and our property manager
and so I kind of like scale them up with
little little services and then finally
like I see her being one who could
manage like she could probably manage a
couple of my airbnbs and own uh part of
that company and so you could think
about at the most micro scale like
everybody probably has a door guy at
your building who's just incredible
every single time or the guy the valet
who Parks your car every single time and
it's amazing and then if you're a little
bit higher level you probably have that
person that works inside your company
that you know you won't be able to keep
forever in that position but if you
funded them into something else they
would crush it and so I think it's this
secret of talent management and talent
retention we used to think about it like
how do I keep people in the company for
a long time and I think the 21st century
way to do it is to think about how do I
keep people in my ecosystem for a really
long time and if you can do that then
you can have people work for you for 20
years but they can become owners too
right alongside you you create your own
meaning we were meant to be creators so
I don't think you should wait for your
purpose I think you need to make it
that's where all the happiness is is the
intersection of the things that you like
and the things that make money you have
to be the architect of your own life the
biggest mistake you can make is let
somebody else write your story and
that's what most of us do most of us
actually let other people tell us how
our life should be structured here's
what I think you should do to make sure
that you don't screw up on this check
out this tweet in particular every
Sunday I sit myself down in a chair just
like this and I ask myself a series of
questions to make sure that I'm on the
path that I want not somebody else's
some of the questions are things like
how much of this week did you enjoy what
percentage of the tasks that you had to
do were things that you wanted to do how
happy or tired do you feel at the end of
the day those small things multiply how
the hell did you stop people pleasing
stop putting yourself first and not
worry about what everyone else thought
of
you it took me years and I really had to
do it completely by myself I think a lot
of people stay in quiet desperation
because they share with other people and
they get talked out of the thing that
deep down inside they know to be true
and so it's almost the opposite of what
we're told in things like AA or when
we're having difficulties tell somebody
else let your community help you for me
it was I don't want to tell anybody else
because they see this perfect thing and
they're going to think what's wrong with
you like aren't you grateful enough why
would you leave and so it was a solo
mission that I knew that I had to take
my parents knew about it uh the day
before I told him that I was going to
get a divorce and not a moment sooner
none of my friends knew about it uh
except one that I went to to live and
stay with uh that night when I left and
um I think the moment where I felt that
I could not live another day in that
marriage was when I looked at we had two
friends that were married 10 years older
than us we went on a group trip together
the four of
us and they were you know wealthier than
we were they had kids together they were
sort of 10 years in the the future for
us
and I remember you know my husband at
the time looking at me and saying like
you know one day that'll be us and I
just was horrified and I thought there's
nothing I want less than that and so if
I could project myself into the future
and that is what 10 years looks like if
I don't make a move today I will end up
at a place where somebody else has
become the architect of my life instead
of myself and so that moment changed
everything and now whenever I'm in those
difficult moments I try to project
forward do I want this thing that I'm
striving for hm let me look at somebody
else who has it and if I don't want
their life the things that are around
them the type of happiness that I see
exuding from them then I'm going to
probably stop chasing that you want me
to tell you a little secret that is
absolutely not PC and maybe we get our
YouTube video kicked off it's that fit
people make 25k more per year than not
fit people in fact this isn't the only
one there's another one that says you
earn 9% % more a year if you hit the gym
so if I earn 1 million a year that's
another $90,000 if it's 9% another
spoiler it's going to hurt is
good-looking people earn 12% more over
the course of their lifetime now this
all seems shallow AF really but like the
truth is this comes back to Darwinism
which basically means survival of the
fittest historically we were looking for
who could produce the best Offspring and
who could protect them so I guess it
really all comes back to sex but truly
getting into shape is is one of the best
things you can do in your 20s so do
yourself a favor get a gym membership
cut out the processed foods spend more
on that Whole Food's organic stuff get
the boxing coach skip the alcohol a
little bit still have some fun but maybe
not all the time there's tons of ways to
mess with businesses but basically you
want to ask yourself how could this
business go to zero and how could I
protect myself from it don't fall in
love with any businesses or any deals my
dad always said never fall in love with
something that can't love you back
really important that you remember that
there's so many deals that you could
swim and them it's the kiss of death
that you get too far down the road with
a deal and you have sunk cost fallacy
which means because you spend a bunch of
time in cash on it you think that you
still need to do this deal you fall in
love with the deal let me show you what
this looks like you're about to close
the seller knows that so right before
you go to close he says I need a little
bit more cash or I can't give you enough
financing these tiny paper cuts they
bleed you out so hold the line I think
most things that are worth it take some
hard work so that's one side so let's be
real about it and I think humans can
feel real you can feel it in your gut
when you hear it and then on the flip
side of that uh I don't like lazy I like
some risk and it's actually it's quite
hard and we could use Sam and Sean in
his example it's hard to to be okay with
a little cringe like to be okay saying
something like no small boy energy like
people could you know it feels like
maybe not that intelligent or not that
sophisticated and so people don't want
to do the like slightly cringe thing of
putting a half- naked person on your you
know pool card right like it it's some
like somehow some reputational or ego
risk to good marketing and I'm sure
there's like some vernacular you guys
have about that but I feel like most
people go lazy and they go simple and
they go copycat and I actually say the
opposite to my team one of our core
culture codes at contrarian thinking is
better to be wrong than to be boring and
and I think that's really important
because you can you can take risks and
you can fail but don't fail short when
I'm looking at buying a new business I
do step one is always I typically find
the operator first I'm always starting
with who's the guy or gal that's going
to run this thing for me um and then I'm
vetting them like we talked about humans
background checks references past work
and after I found that human then I'm
looking for operator and me fit so not
that's not just like culturally how are
we together that's like well with the
money that I have and the resources that
I have and the skill sets this guy has
and the resource he has what's a good
business for the two of us to do
together and then finally I'm probably
thinking you know what business can we
buy that this person can operate that
fits in that little middle of our vend
diagram and um and there's lots of ways
to structure it I think the most
important part for you just learning is
to realize that if you don't want to run
the business you have to find the human
before you find the business most people
go and try to find the business and hope
that the human's in the business or they
think that they can go higher at the
business and you can do all of those
things it's just hard we've all hired
before hiring great people is really
hard hiring somebody else to run your
business and your dream not theirs is
also really hard so I start with a human
and then I go to the business then you
can get to structuring like you know do
we vest the equity right away what are
the cliffs how much money do we pay them
what percentage of Revenue or profit um
which you can again slice 57 ways from
Sunday how much time do you spend on
that analysis I let a lot of things go
by the wayside one of the most important
things I keep reminding myself is that
no is an actually wonderful word no is
an incredible word to use more often and
so is the ignore button you know I got a
lot of on Twitter because I posted like
leave your text messages unread um I
don't respond to a lot of text messages
I don't respond to a ton of emails um I
don't take phone calls you can't pay me
enough money somebody reached out with
like a number that I thought was crazy
to just to test you know test my resolve
I guess for an hour phone call and I was
like no I just I don't do it because I
will get distracted too quickly and I'm
a golden retriever I want to chase
tennis balls right all over the place
and so um a lot of mine is I let
lowlevel stuff fly all the time and uh
that's one and then two I think I just
have gotten in this process of
continuously each week because I'm a
writer writing this stuff down that's my
favorite part about content is it makes
it gives me like the right to do Recaps
and post-ops because I turn it into
content then it's one of my favorite
reasons for getting on the Internet so
every single week when we have our
investment committee and I learn
something new or a deal goes bad and I'm
writing the newsletter for next week or
I'm writing more content for our
business buying group it's real time
what's happening to me in our businesses
and I don't think I could do content and
running the businesses if the two
weren't intermingled at the same time I
think that like any partnership
Partnerships are incredibly difficult
and so you would really have to find
partner partner fit and in my situation
I have a guy Chris who is sort of my
right hand and he like he couldn't want
to be in front of the camera less he
just doesn't he's not interested you
know and he couldn't want to come up
with crazy ideas less he actually just
all his entire job and what he likes to
do is we call him the vibe killer and he
loves it he's like no just like do this
nope we didn't say we were doing this
we're not doing that other shiny object
we're just right here nope Cody nope and
so in all my career I've always
surrounded myself I had another one
called April she was amazing she went on
to be the CEO of my last company and so
in this instance I think it works for us
but you're right where I see it go wrong
Kip and you have way more experience
than this I was actually talking to my
agents at night media that that I work
with for YouTube stuff and they were
pitching me a bunch of different ideas
and stuff they were going to do with
other creators and I was like here's
your problem most creators suck to work
with they want to talk about whatever
they want to talk about they don't
actually close product and they don't
have high conversion With Their audience
Their audience doesn't want to buy and
they they're not willing to do the
pushing pushing pushing of product that
you have to do if you actually want
people to to sell over time and so I
think that's your your your red flag so
if you're a great operator finding
creators who inherently want to build a
business not build Fame is really tough
and and and important the number one
best purchase you can make is to trade
your time for knowledge not money so
this is where I tell you to work for
free yep the internet hates this but
while it doesn't technically cost you
anything it is probably the most
expensive purchase you can make in your
20s your friends are going to be out
there flashing their big paycheck or
bragging about all the money they made
in their startup on Twitter and I'm
going to tell you to do something else
go find the work that teaches you the
most humanly possible and completely and
utterly disregard the paycheck here's
the worst thing you can do instead of
that an MBA I have an MBA from
Georgetown University and a PhD from a
school in Brazil called fund Vargas do I
regret doing it yeah kind of even though
my work paid for it now if you can get
into Harvard Yale Stanford MIT and want
to go into High Finance consulting or
being exact at a Fortune 500 by all
means go pay the 200k to hear people
talk not do but for anyone else take the
100K go to the best business school
there is it's called business as a
school you got to keep your day job I
kept my day job for just about 10 years
before I finally left if this is your
first deal do me a favor you can invest
do deals but also keep your salary your
salary is like a Lifeline to oxygen
above water until you learn to swim by
yourself keep it until you're sure you
really know what you've gotten yourself
into that is unless you have one of the
big three which I consider cash to cover
any downside inside knowledge on the
business having done it before AKA
you're an accountant you buy an
accounting firm or three investors that
CIA this one's so important partners you
got to proceed with caution imagine
every partner you have is going to leave
you data says about 70% of our
Partnerships fail Our Generation stays
at a business or a job for 3 years on
average so that new co-founder that you
have it's likely they won't be the
person that you grow old with I didn't
have a lot of rules for partners when I
started now I do no Partners get Equity
upfront without cash in the game never
give away Equity without a vesting
schedule they need to do the deal with
you put in the same amount of cash as
you and they need to still vest so they
can't walk away leaving you stuck with
the best
second is no 50/50 partner someone needs
to be in control and it's probably you
or whoever has the most skin in the game
you also need to make sure you have a
partnership agreement something like
this with clear deliverables on both
sides and a pre-exit provision if it
doesn't work out think of it like
writing a prenup before you get married
when you get rich and or famous you
start to get around other people that
are rich and famous what's interesting
then is they can see who's real and
who's not like this and you start to
Crave actually the respect of people
that you respect and so I've seen it
implode real fast because you know I
have a I have a a friend and he's young
and he's done well made couple let's
call it tens of millions of dollars
online now but he's done it in ways that
people just don't kind of want to
associate with it and so it's also it's
this empty thing you have to pretend to
a legion of humans listening to you that
you're the real deal and yet at the same
time you
feel you can feel it and so you know
I've talked to him about it a decent
amount I'm like man you've got the thing
you're just chasing the wrong rabbit and
so you've got to find your actual real
rabbit because you're never going to
have the respect just from the likes and
clicks and you'll get it once you're
around a bunch of humans who are like oh
he's a builder oh he's got interesting
ideas no no no he's not a hustler cuz
that's not really what the people that
you want respect from are interested in
it's like no he's a he's a Creator and
by that I mean a creator of value in
this world and most people don't know to
strive for that they think that we walk
around comparing our bank accounts like
no no did you see this I'm real it's
like no we I have no idea what's in your
bank you have no I have no idea and also
if I told you you told me we wouldn't
what does that mean nothing you can't
talk about that over a dinner table you
talk about what ideas are in your head
and things are you building that are
worthwhile for us to have a conversation
that doesn't feel like we're at the
shallow end and at a certain point
that's where you want go when you've had
some success entrepreneurship is 5%
timing 5% idea 10% talent and 80% not
fcking stopping I thought about this
when somebody was asking me what are the
keys to being successful and I go back
to the study by Angela Duckworth about
the one thing that she found across
Decades of studying was those who were
more successful had more grit than
everybody else and she determined that
by ability to continuously confront pain
and move through it so how long could
you handle pain and that is actually
what entrepreneurship is my dad says at
some point in the middle of the night
you will be sitting in the dark on your
couch heading your hands wondering what
the do I do next and that's just
the nature of the game can you handle
those moments a lot of people can't
they'd rather kind of Coast through life
with a low level of anxiety of not
achieving the things that they want but
the truth about entrepreneurship and
making money is it's just pain how much
pain can you tolerate and none of it's
going to kill you if you just keep
moving forward
I'm not sure you deserve the right to be
an owner if you can't have difficult
conversations and so I think a little
bit of this is having a conversation
with yourself and saying am I the type
of human who wants to lead people who
wants to be an owner who wants to leave
a mark on this world and if so there are
a few things that I have to add to my
tool belt through life and one of them
is that I have to release people when
they are not a fit for my company and
when I am not a fit for them and the
second that you real realiz that one
it's always worse than you think it it's
always it's always better than you think
it's going to be very seldom have I ever
fired somebody where they've one been
surprised or two it's gone badly and
that's because it's really important to
your point about managing them out and
this stuff is kind of tactical and
people who don't lead teams or run
businesses don't love talking about this
actually at all but it's really
important that you have check-ins early
and you get comfortable with friction so
I'm always telling my managers like stop
giving compliments to people on your te
that are underperforming just because it
makes you feel better like you have to
have the tough conversation how terrible
would it be if you were R learning to
ride a bike and every time you fell over
your parents were just like yeah just
keep doing that that yeah didn't work
but like you should keep doing exactly
that way where you keep leaning all the
way over to the left they're never going
to learn to ride the bike and so as a
good leader you have to be able to say
hey man like your sales numbers are down
you're not making enough phone calls do
you want me to listen into to what's
going on there and to actually give
people feedback and then people won't be
surprised with something happens because
you will have been coaching them in and
up or out for a period of time already I
remember when I went to go ask for my
raise I was like what is a way where I
could decrease this sucking for him
because it's awful when somebody asks
you for a raise and his employee you
can't give it to them or you don't think
they're as an employer or you don't
think that they're actually worth that
um and so there's this tension obviously
that happens immediately and everybody
all the time is coming to you as an
employer asking for more more money and
so you can actually really negatively
impact the the relationship but I said
okay I'm going to come up with a kind of
a fun way that I could ask him where he
is never going to have felt this before
and simultaneously will feel like it's
low risk so I like searched around on
the internet and I kind of found this
idea of I got a cocktail napkin and on
the cocktail napkin I wrote on it uh
like a couple numbers like the first
number was uh the growth that I was
going to have in the business I think it
was from a revenue perspective like the
second number was what our profits were
going to be in the business that I was I
was working in in my little lane and and
then the third was what I wanted
and I pulled the napkin out in a meeting
with Andy and I'm all sweaty and I'm
nervous and I um said you know Andy
somewhere I read that um any idea worth
having at some point was written on a
cocktail napkin and so I said I uh want
to earn more money at this company but I
fully understand that in order to earn
more money I have to make more money for
the company so I brought you an idea for
what I think I could increase and grow
within the company that would be really
material to you and if I did those
things maybe I could make this number at
the bottom and if that number isn't
right for you I'd love to have a
conversation on what it would take for
me to get to that bottom number and we
could adjust the top ones and he kind of
like looked at me he like like what's
wrong with you know it's just like
defused the situation and so as an
employee those little negotiation
tactics I did them at least once a year
and sometimes I did them by annually if
I was really killing it um led me to
being one of the better paid people
pretty consistently um and then I always
usually asked for any ability to
co-invest in deals we were doing so it
was like I'm going to put my I believe
in what we're doing so much here I'd
like to put my money into a deal I'm not
asking you for anything I'm asking for
you to like maybe let me put 5K in and
that led to me accelerating my my cash
faster each of us we have something I
call it inside of us this thing this
thing we're supposed to do this thing
we're uniquely good at this thing that
we can't help but do for the love of it
and what happens if we were able to do
that thing if we were able to through
our small businesses pay for our rent
and mortgage and kids and colleges and
all the things and thus lean into that
other voice inside so I'm only going to
read you 30 seconds but I hope you leave
with this idea of what is your it and
I'm going to borrow some words from
another and then I'm going to leave you
with some words of my own I got the idea
for for the it after reading a a poem
from Charles Bukowski and uh it struck a
chord really deep inside about the
wrongness of letting others become the
architect of your life and you walk
around and in a house that doesn't feel
like yours and how instead could you be
the one to build that foundation and so
here it goes if it and by it I mean what
you choose to dedicate your life to
doesn't flow out of you like blood from
a mortal wound don't do it if it doesn't
stream Rivers don't do it find the thing
whose tide cannot be stemmed we each
have it we each just need to find it and
then more importantly perhaps summon the
courage to do it I got this from this
poem uh so you want to become a writer
from Bukowski and he says don't be like
so many writers don't be like so many
thousands of people who call themselves
writers don't be dull and pretentious
and boring and consumed with self-love
the libraries of the world yawn
themselves to sleep over your kind don't
add to it don't do it unless it comes
out of your soul like a rocket unless
being still would drive you to Madness
or suicide or murder don't do it unless
the sun inside you is burning your gut
don't do it when it is truly time and if
you have been chosen it will do it by
itself and it will keep on doing it
until you die or it dies in you there is
no other way and there never was that's
by Bukowski a poet and a bit of a Madman
and so what I'll say to all of you is
that to all my fellow mad men and women
to all of my fellow contrarians and
creators and builders business buyers
may you find your it and I can promise
you one thing although you may do a cash
flow deal although you might buy that
car wash although perhaps a laundromat
is in your future that's not your it it
is the first step on your stairway up to
whatever that thing is inside of you
that you can't do but for lack of dying
if you speak the language of money you
usually make more of it man this one is
so true there's a bunch of words they
use in finance that take people from
really really rich to outside of the
loop entirely most of us don't speak the
language of finance and I think that's
on purpose I think people in finance do
not want you to know the secrets to
wealth because that makes it easier for
them to keep it but there are so many
terms iida Roi cash onh return expense
ratio the list goes on and on and on
actually there's a whole article here on
it if you want it but if you actually
want to get real wealth you have to
learn the main terms it's pretty easy to
do actually you could take a couple
courses on YouTube but this was actually
told to me by one of the wealthiest
Partners uh at Goldman Sachs they came
down in the beginning and did a little
lunch and learn with us when I was at
the firm and we were asking a bunch of
questions and he was using jargon iida
for instance and I remember one of the
people in the room raised their hands
and they said what does the term iida
mean can you explain that and he kind of
looked at the person with like snoody
Goldman air as we did and said I don't
know how you got a job at this firm
without speaking the language of money
that term exactly the language of money
and he said you go find the answer to
that I'm not here to be your dictionary
and it was such a perfectly Goldman
response but actually he was right so it
always stuck with me learn the terms
then you can make the cash when I was
younger I think I had a lot of stories
about um you know why I needed my dad
for a lot of things for instance in a
positive way like in an incredibly
positive way but that led me to bad
Partnerships like I knew that I had to
redo Partnerships and totally learn how
to partner up with somebody and I think
a lot of people this is one of the
things that I obsess on with humans is
and you know this very well but I obsess
on humans choosing the right Partners to
go through life with from a business
perspective I don't know about marriage
and otherwise I've done well you know
well thus far hopefully but um but when
it comes to businesses I see so many
humans partner with whoever is in front
of them not set the terms not start with
the end in mind not write a prenup to
their business and what people don't
realize if you go to venture capitalist
and you ask them what are some of their
top three things while they why they
would invest in a business or another
one of the very first things is they
want co-founders why that doesn't seem
like a great idea to me most people get
divorced because they make them set
parameters for the divorce that could
potentially happen and they know that
entrepreneurship is so hard it's likely
one of them will fail or want to be but
the other one won't and so if you think
about that in every business venture
that you do you've partnered with a ton
of people you know partnership is really
really powerful but it's really hard and
so the past experience of me thinking
that I need my dad everywhere led me to
partner with other men that I
immediately thought were as great as he
was and then realized oh not everybody's
my dad I've got to be a little bit
tighter I've got to be a little bit more
thoughtful partnership what I really
want people to do is learn the framework
so um I want you to be able to buy your
first business that either supplements
your salary if you want to exit your
company or supplements your expenses and
so I want to teach people how do you buy
a small business that can either replace
what I'm making right now or that can
replace my expenses so that I can
continue to do the work if I want to uh
at my job but I never have to I can have
my you fund uh that's that's funded from
something else and um and so that's the
first step and then what you'll quickly
realize is once you buy a business and
the average person who goes through our
program buys a business typically in 11
months and that business is somewhere
between $100,000 to $10 million in total
revenue and um and we screen people
because not everybody should do this and
so we screen them to kind of make sure
are you are you sure you're ready for
this and what I found is what happens is
you'll buy your first business and then
you'll spend anywhere from 90 days to a
year a year and a half kind of
stabilizing that business running
through it but then you're going to add
different what I call Revenue lines um
that could be income lines to an
individual through your business so
you're going to say all right I bought a
laundromat and now I want to increase
the revenue of the laundromat so I'm
going to add vending machines as another
Revenue line and then because I see how
that H works I'm going to add vending
machines for soap and then because I see
how that works I'm going to add a wash
and fold service and then I'm going to
add a delivery service and what you're
basically doing is you're diversifying
your revenue streams through one
business so there is a focus or a
through line to your business um but
you're being really smart in acquiring
your new profit centers and that's
something I wish I learned earlier
because I always thought you had to grow
organically like I've got to go and I've
got to get this one customer this one
client but what if instead you could
acquire the clients and wrap them up
inside of your business and that's what
I tend to do uh again and again but the
only caveat I would say there is that I
do think you need to focus on
skills early as opposed to income so I
have a model that says learn earn invest
most people go I want to invest I want
to invest and make money but really what
you have to do is first you have to
let's say let's say you wanted to buy a
boring business you need to spend a
minute learning about buying a Boran
business 90 days some people take a year
but let's say that one-ear trial uh
period of really learning how to execute
on Deal Mak and while you're doing that
want you to earn money and I want you to
learn how to increase your earnings
potential so whether that's negotiating
for a higher salary or whether that's
getting a better job with a better
salary or whether that's doing
commissions and after you've done those
two things then I want you to use that
money and I want you to invest it in
something or invest your time or
expertise and so that's kind of how I
push people to start thinking about
diversification of Revenue lines one you
know invest in you before you invest in
assets I buy boring businesses I teach
people how to buy boring business
businesses the first thing I say to
everybody is like don't do any action
for the next 90 days don't buy something
don't invest in something your singular
job is to spend at least an hour a day
learning about investing you will never
I can guarantee you you will never
regret spending the time learning what
it means to make money either through
investing or through earning um so
that's the first thing don't make little
Investments the biggest mistake I see
people make and one of the people on my
team did this she was listening to a
dude on the internet who I'm actually
friends with funny enough he was talking
about day trading and she spent
$5,000 following his advice to day trade
I said do you find yourself uh obsessed
with this game of of day trading or
investing do you think that you are one
of the best in the world at it are you
getting really smart of the game at the
game of it or are you just attempting to
speculate and get rich quick because
that is the fastest way to lose your
money right um so that's one two uh it's
the old adage that we all know to be
true which
is I think you should be the poorest and
the dumbest in as many rooms as you
possibly can and I try to do that
continuously trying to do it with
Fitness right now actually because I
want a six-pack so I want to see if the
six like do they rub off are they
contagious un sure do un sure um but
somebody said to me something I really
liked which is um you should be if you
want to achieve a goal get in a friend
group where your goal is their Norm yeah
and that really flipped something for me
because when it's my goal to have a
six-pack uh and eat healthy but the
people I'm hanging around all already
have sixpacks and eat healthy their Norm
is what I want their goal will help me
get to my goal way faster and so uh
that's the second thing it's just
getting in the right rooms and then
probably the the third is armato it's
question everything you're told stuff by
me stuff by you your ability to hear an
idea even well or beautifully
articulated write it down and then go do
I agree with this m hm I'm not sure I do
what about second and third order
effects of this situation that critical
thinking component will save people from
poor investment decisions and it'll save
them from poor career decisions um and
it will make them become a thinker as
opposed to a follower if you sit next to
an uh a high performer yeah so if you
have your team sit next to a high
performer you do you will outperform by
15% so a high performer just in your
proximity will increase your performance
by 15% if you sit next to a low
performer or underperformer it will
decrease your productivity by
30% so every B player you bring on board
is not just decreasing their
productivity by 30% it is that energy
transfer which is that everybody around
them becomes a little bit less
productive and I think one of the
reasons people want to be owners of
companies is because they feel that
people want to stay at companies where
there's a bunch of winners it's why I
liked Goldman I was like these guys are
so smart I'm learning so much I want to
keep going when I was at Vanguard I was
like oh my God these schleps are just
schlepping around the office not doing
anything I'm not learning anything and
they're by you know design sort of
pulling you back and down and so I I
keep that number on a notepad next to my
computer for me to one not be the
underperformer and two it's not just
about getting rid of underperformers for
you as a CEO it's not good to do to your
team so you know we've definitely have
have had them in varying companies of
mine but we push relentlessly to either
make people better or help them find the
thing that they can be an a performer at
all right so what's an operator it's the
thing that allows me to own 26
businesses that are all cash flowing as
I'm talking to you tell me more it's the
thing that allows Buffett to find time
for that McDonald's every morning it's
also the thing that could allow you to
save small business owners from closing
their doors forever you're the bridge to
the Future so Warren Buffett realized
this wanted to be a billionaire he
realized he needed an operator inter
Charlie Munger Warren and Charlie both
became billionaires through through
Warren finding the deals and Charlie
operating them then Charlie hired a
bunch of people just like him and
instead of doing what most bosses do
which is micromanage he lived by this
quote when you buy a dog you don't do
the Barking for it small words really
impactful when you hire an operator you
don't do the operating for them we help
find you your operating bulldog and it's
probably not how you think let's find
these people we got a case study first
this is Miss Nevada does mail I call it
all right my friend Lisa scaled her mini
mailbox business while running three
other companies do you think she licks
the stamps and slaps them on the boxes
day in and day out not in those heels
she doesn't because Lisa understands the
upside of having operators that could
manage her business while she's working
she hired cocktail waitresses off the
Vegas Strip brilliant look at these
ladies you don't get to be in the
service industry for long if you aren't
a quick learner and a natural Hustler
also you age out also also if you do
this no one slaps your ass at the mail
store slap that one hiring decision to
take waitresses and turn them into
owners and operators has made her more
than
$250,000 a year how do people buy
businesses for $0 and make them hundreds
of thousands of dollars well this
business was a 12-year-old website and
the strategy that I Ed to buy this
business is one that I use again and
again and again that has four steps I
call it the four rules for business buy
with $0 down so the strategy is called
sou wow sou and there's four simple
steps to it here's step number
one day landromat lrat business car
washes car washes what does this mean
this is a business that hasn't changed
much this is a business that uses fax
machines it uses Hardline
phones yo what's
up a business that hasn't used
technology and wouldn't even know what
to do with two letters like a i these
businesses are all around the business I
bought is called approachment this
business was in existence since the
early 2000s and the owner of this
business was 65 years old he hadn't
changed a single thing on the website in
12 years was full of stock images that
basically make you unsure what the
business does overall
boring the business does two things it
pairs offshore Talent that answer
responses to businesses with technology
that allows businesses to respond 24/7
almost immediately to any lead CU it
turns out if they don't respond they
don't get clients so I bought this step
one stale business and I did it from an
owner because he hadn't changed much
over 12 years hasn't changed a bit step
two old the oldest restaurant the oldest
Winery oldest company this was an old
business the owner of this business had
been in multiple businesses for many
years he ran this company approachment
he ran a Contracting Company he also had
some construction company interests the
reason I like old businesses is because
they have something called the Lindy
effect which basically means the longer
something has been in existence the more
likely it is it will continue to be in
existence so this business has been
around for 12 years which actually means
it's more reasonable that it'll be
around for the next 12 Years a startup
that's only been around for 6 months
probably not going to have a very good
score based on the Lindy effect except
most people think that because
businesses are old they're worthless
well that's where you're wrong and you
can buy a business at much of a discount
because most people assume that it ain't
very good and it's not going to go very
far now the company approachment I
actually reached out to because I was a
user of their services I used their chat
I loved it it increased my business's
Revenue a ton by never once missing a
response to my customers and so I asked
him how's it going I said to the owner
are you still interested in running this
business it seems like retirement is
like on the horizon for you what are you
thinking and he agreed so I look for
businesses that are old if you are a
startup I'm a no if you're a hope and
dream and not profitable I'm a no thank
you if you have proprietary in the word
no way all right step three weak
competition competition competition
competition what does this mean I want a
business that doesn't have really good
competition I would never buy an AI
business right now why I'm competing
with open Ai and Google and Microsoft
who knows who else with billions and
billions and billions of dollars going
after that when I'm competing against my
BL scaping companies my roofing
companies my car washes my laundromats
do you think any of the other
competitors in the space are ones to be
feared the answer no you're looking for
companies that don't even use text
automation you're looking for companies
that have never focused on marketing or
social media their competition is weak
and you are going to provide the
antithesis to weak you're going to build
a real business on top of a boring
business step
four simple this is incredibly important
and probably where people mess up the
most they hear words like biotechnology
and they instantly think the business is
worth more they hear words like
proprietary and they want to start
investing we want a stupid simple
business and the reason why is because
we want to be able to understand tiny
little levers that we can use to change
a business that's why any of these 150
businesses I would invest in let me tell
you a few that aren't so simple
biotechnology no AI technology probably
not anything patent pendy I'm going to
be a no you want me to invest in the
next hot startup or something with the
word algorithm in it also probably no
these are businesses that are so simple
like inserting a coin into a washer or
dryer having said washer or dryer run
and then finally taking the profit out
of it boring businesses often equal
billions do you think it's uh necessary
to take that pain early or if in a in an
alternative in an alternate universe
could you have enjoyed that process
while also getting all the benefits from
it that's a good question like uh I
think I did enjoy the process I think I
learned to love pain and struggle okay
and uh and there were the only thing
that was the hard for me is being really
really tired I can see that why that's a
torture tactic because there were days
where you had to focus and I would be
like you know I'm like I'm barely here
right now um that was really tough but
actually the long hours working on
interesting problem set is is not a
problem but I think it is a and I was
just thinking about this this week I had
a tough week this week stuff going on in
the companies lots of work no sleeping
and um and I was writing about reminding
myself why do I keep doing this I don't
technically need to keep doing this you
probably don't technically need to keep
doing this so why and the reason is
because I think that the struggle is a
bit of an honor and I think if you want
to know what the key to happiness is
it's struggle if you want to know what
the key to wealth is it's struggle if
you want to know what the the key to
making a lot of money is it's struggle
and the more that you can realize that
iron actually does sharpen iron and the
more sort of difficult things you can
champion and do the more likely you are
to have a successful life um I I think
it's a life hack it's a secret that
these days we don't want to hear now
everybody wants you know I want to do
the least and make the most I want to
hire the least amount of people and have
the biggest company I'm a solo
entrepreneur will never employ anybody
that makes millions on the internet and
you can do it too without any work and 4
hours a week like that's the thing that
we've said we want and then I think
about it for a second I stand back and
I'm like is that really what we want
like what happened to building Empires
what happened to leaving leges what are
you going to do in the other 52 hours of
your week and so I don't think you have
to struggle forever but I think periods
of struggle make the periods of
relaxation really poignant and with one
without the other is like a day without
a night
nobody wants to live in complete
pleasure and happiness always because it
diminishes and so I do think you need it
you are putting a lot of effort into
social media I am putting a lot of
effort into social media why why are you
doing it what's the point of growing
this is this just ego is it you know cuz
there's probably a little bit that's
definitely drives me but like what like
why do you do it I started it uh in 2020
for a couple different reasons one was I
got a little bored because I wasn't
doing Road shows and private Equity like
I was for theast like 15 years run
around every week you know the deal
raising money from investors vetting
deals I was working like 60 70 80 hour
weeks and when Co happened I had a
little bit of time and I actually got to
take a step back and think for a minute
and in that period I was trying to think
about uh leverage so basically what is
the highest leverage activity for my
time that I could spend in this moment
and for most of my career I hadn't
thought that way I had really sort of
thought what's the next step in my
career and then the next step but
there's a power play to determining how
you want to spend your time and if you
can actually think okay what is the you
know as Archimedes said give me a a
fulcrum and a lever give me a fulcrum
and a lever to place upon it and and uh
if you have a long enough version you
can move the world right and so I kind
of thought about that with social media
and I think I read a post from nval rant
that basically talked about the three
levels of Leverage which was first
employment uh or people you know you
could do something bigger than yourself
if you convinced other people to join
you and then the second lever was
Capital most of the big wealthy humans
that we know through time as Titans like
the Rockefellers and the Roth shes were
created during the Banking Act Right
when we got access to other people's
Capital at scale and then the third was
code Bezos musk um Gates all of these
guys had Early Access to technology
before other people did and so they had
an army of robots quote unquote online
and the fourth one that he hadn't talked
about enough yet was audience and
audience in my mind is the first
permissionless form of Leverage Banks
you had to ask for the money code you
had to have access to the technology and
for humans you needed money to pay them
right and now we had audience and I
thought wait a second I'm running around
trying to raise capital for investment
deals I'm doing you know I'm in the
million Mile Club I'm doing 100,000 plus
miles a a year um it's actually not that
fun what would it look like if instead
of me going to people I brought them to
me and once I started looking at the
power of social media I thought oh my
this is I can't believe I haven't seen
this before in finance we don't
typically do social media because unlike
real estate we have way tighter rules
for for raising capital and so um I
remember I worked at a firm where I was
had all these licenses you know 66 and
63 and Series 7 and 24 and um my firm
said you know if you say anything
publicly you can move the markets I'm
like bro it's like me and my mom on here
nobody's following my stuff yet um but
they basically you know my CEO at the
time said to me we get rich quietly um
you know we we get rich quietly and we
don't talk about it we don't make a
ruckus and I thought I don't know I
think we could like get rich in public
if we did it the right way and so that
convinced me oh I'm going to build a
huge social audience I'm going to never
do another steak dinner and I'm going to
see how big this could get it turns out
it's I was right the people who love you
they want what's best for them typically
which is that you're safe you're secure
everything's okay they don't really want
what's quote unquote best for you
because that's actually the scary thing
real growth happens when you take huge
risks and you potentially fail and you
realize that you're not going to die and
so I realized that my loved ones were
some of the reasons that were actually
holding me back um super supportive but
they were always saying things like is
the grass Always Greener Cody you know
what about this next thing is that
really going to make you happy you know
are you sure it's not you is it them and
in some cases they're right I just have
that that ridiculous urge to keep
growing and doing more but that that
made me jump from 1 2 3 4 5 five finance
companies in like 10 years or something
like that because I thought it was each
it was the individual company and I
didn't realize oh no I'm just like
unemployable I want to work for myself
I'm not going to be great at being at
somebody else's employee um but it was
the stories that I heard again and again
from my family because they wanted to
keep me safe very kind but not right for
me what advice would you give to
16-year-old Cody who maybe she's she's
got a, through mowing the lawn and
through tutoring maths or something and
she's got $1,000 and she's like I want
to invest this ,000 how would you
approach that conversation with your
younger self well I'll tell you what I
tell my cousins now who are right about
that age so to my 16 18-year-old cousins
I say take the big risk now while you
have no responsibility the more
responsibility you get the scarier the
risk becomes when you have kids when you
have a mortgage when you have a big
paycheck check that you could lose it's
scary to go start a business to think
about buying a business to think about
being the operator in a business um but
when you're young you should take all
the risk human possible because failure
doesn't really matter when you're young
um I don't think you should take $1,000
and invest it in anything when you're
young unless you're investing it in
yourself or you're investing it in a big
risk like trying to potentially turn
$1,000 into a $100,000 business purchase
interesting
not no no no no I mean there's uh in in
investing we say um we say that those
people are speculators not investors and
there's a whole generation of people
that have been taught speculation not
investing anytime you have the last man
fallacy which is that the person who
comes in next that you're going to sell
to is the one is the dumb one that's
going to be holding the bag you should
know that you should run away from that
because you're the last man we don't
want to be a nation of people who are
trying to kind of dupe people into being
the next person to buy it at a higher
valuation than we did we want to have
assets that are so good that you think
like Warren Buffett and you want to hold
them for 30 years you have to pry that
business out of my cold dead hands
because it's a great business and I
think because we had that fast money run
of nfts and Bitcoin and stocks people
get confused and you know the other
thing that's that's so true is really
good Finance people who trade stocks
have something called a black box they
don't even tell their salespeople that
go and rep their product what's inside
of their algorithms it's fireal you
can't see inside why because I would
never tell somebody my unfair advantage
that everybody else could go replicate
immediately if trading is the way that I
make money so anybody that teaches
trading online is totally full of it in
my opinion because if they had great
secrets they would never share them they
just pile as much money as humanly
possible into it and buy a bunch of
Bentleys um um and so I'm really
cautious on speculators and I'm really
bullish on
ownership so how might said 16-year-old
or said cousin actually invest that ,000
you invested in yourself I think you
need to learn at that point you have to
learn then you increase your earnings
then you invest no 16-year-old should be
taking their thousand bucks and putting
in the S&P in my opinion they will make
so much more money by taking that
thousand bucks and going and learning
how to create a bunch of YouTube videos
or going and learning how to buy
businesses or going and learning how to
talk to people and negotiate whatever
the case may be I would take the
thousand bucks and I would consider it
your little MBA money and I think spend
like that until you can start putting
you can do the S&P 500 putting 10% of
your savings in I've done that for a
long long time but that won't make you
rich uh it'll just potentially beat
inflation Cody do you have any final
advice for someone who's listening who
wants to get into the business of boring
businesses twofold one I think You' got
guys did a really good job of not making
it sound too simplistic and easy you
know you too can buy a business with
zero doar spend zero time on it become a
millionaire have a Lambo and a yacht
like that's not what we're talking about
here and on the flip side of that also
assume that you as a human are much more
capable than you're giving yourself
credit for and assume that you've met a
lot of business owners how smart did you
think all of them were have you been
impressed by every business owner that
you've engaged with the answer is no
I've met a bunch of the big type
business owners and I can tell you what
10% of the time I have blown away and
90% of the time I think I'm coming for
you and so for those listening if it
does sound like you are the type of
human that wants to own a business that
wants to make the impact that I think is
the most powerful impact any human can
have which is to build something to
employ others and to create so other
people can consume I think there's no
higher calling and I think that buying
businesses allows you to do it when you
don't have that startup seed inside of
you that you would die if you didn't
build it but instead just want to get in
the game and I think getting in the game
is half the battle uh and then you can
figure out what game you want to play
once you get there just do one thing one
thing and and I think that is great for
the beginning focus in the beginning to
become at least a level one expert on
something is really helpful
you know if you are 20 years old and
you're doing 72 activities you're
probably doing none of them very well
that is a quite a fair point but as you
progress in your career you stack
different skills and why couldn't you
also stack different income streams I
think that's a fallacy that you have to
focus on one thing and in fact it's
really dangerous and most people say
well if you don't focus on one thing
you'll never become a billionaire let's
look at the math on billionaires your
likelihood of becoming a billionaire is
less than both getting bitten by a shark
and struck by lightning so unless you
think that you are going to hit both
lightning and a shark attack then you
having a singular Focus to one day
potentially become a billionaire is
numerically just not likely and because
of that what is much more likely
actually is for you to go bankrupt for
you to uh go on unemployment that is
actually 10x more likely and so with
that number in my head I sort of think
okay if I just look at the math if I
ignore all the numbers and all the Nar
sorry if I ignore all The Narrative of
what everybody's saying and I just look
at the math the math tells me that the
most likely outcome
is I uh lose my job I go bankrupt or I
uh end up on on wealthfare or
unemployment because in fact only one
out of 10 people at least in the US dies
wealthy that means independently
financially free to a tune that they can
cover all of their bill do not have to
work and so if that's the real number
then what do I want one and
10 if that's the real number then I just
want to make sure I have multiple income
streams to protect from becoming the
majority and I don't think enough people
do that we spend too much time focusing
on becoming outliers and we forget that
outliers are that for a reason also it's
a story to tell it's much funner to say
here's how I made it my first $100
million and you can too here's how I
made my first million and you can too
okay maybe but maybe we should just try
to get people out of debt first and we
should try to get people stabilized and
we should try to get people a few income
streams and understanding how to better
negotiate their salary let's like start
there for some incredible Mel Robins
motivation watch the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there's one habit that will change
your life and it is do not sleep with
your phone because the one decision
everybody makes that kills your
productivity kills your focus tanks your
mental health is before